okay let's get to the main story the
Democrats have their first scalp former
Trump campaign chairman Paul Manafort
has been indicted on completely
unrelated charges they also got manna
for its right-hand man Rick Gates and
they've apparently also reached a plea
deal with former campaign adviser George
papadopolis not to be confused with
George sucka Leppa guess who is the
former Clinton War Room Clinton
spokesman who pretends to be a
journalist on television this is George
papadopolis nobody it seems has yet
pointed out that the indictment almost
certainly inculpates top Democrats
including Hillary's campaign chairman
John Podesta's brother Tony for context
Hillary Clinton was spotted hobnobbing
with Tony Podesta just this weekend just
like two days ago right now in so much
as this indictment suggests that the
Republicans colluded with Russia
whatever that means
we know that the Democrats colluded with
Russia at least as much and really from
all the evidence available to us the
Democrats committed far graver misdeeds
in colluding with Russia because we now
know that Hillary Clinton and the DNC
paid a foreigner connected with Russia
for alleged dirt on Donald Trump to skew
an American election you know like the
thing that they've been accusing us of
for the last year incessantly yeah they
did we have evidence that they did all
that she then lied not only about the 12
million dollar price tag for that
document but she also absurdly denied
any knowledge of it whatsoever the
president's reaction was typically
trumpian he said sorry but this is years
ago before a Paul Manafort was part of
the Trump campaign but why aren't
crooked Hillary and the Dems the focus
with 5x5 question marks he goes on also
there is no collusion in all caps
employing exclamation point now it is
worth noting it appears the president
Trump has deleted every tweet about mana
for from his timeline so the White House
is not happy about this to say the least
former Trump campaign advisor George
papadopolis is cooperating with the
special counsel and he apparently tried
to set up a meeting with Russian
officials for the purpose of warmer
American relations with Russia you know
to have a Russian reset or something in
order to and these are his words
increases importance as a policy adviser
to the can
Payne so we know that some campaign aid
was offered dirt on Hillary he
apparently tried to get his hands on so
what that doesn't who we know the
Democrats did this we know they paid
millions of dollars for this and I won't
even knock them for it I will not knock
Hillary Clinton for her Oppo research
per se I will knock her for the
ridiculous hypocrisy of accusing your
opponents of doing the very things that
you do but every campaign does this
every campaign tries to get Oppo they
try to get dirt on their opponents
that isn't why Papadopoulos struck a
plea deal the crime that he committed
was lying to the FBI this is always a
bad idea to not lie to the FBI you they
will find you and but the focus on
Papadopoulos is a distraction away from
manna for and the Podesta group and why
this case wasn't prosecuted for so long
we're not talking about crimes that
happened six months ago were talking
about crimes that happened five years
ago so why wasn't it prosecuted the
federal government had all of this
information before the election why is
it being prosecuted now the text of the
indictment points to our answer it reads
quote as part of the scheme in February
2012 manna fort and gates solicited to
Washington DC firms company a and
Company B to lobby in the United States
on behalf of Yanukovych the Party of
Regions and the government of Ukraine
for instance Gates wrote to Company A
that it would be quote representing the
government of Ukraine in Washington DC I
know what you're thinking who exactly
are these elusive companies a and B the
indictment goes on quote to minimize
public disclosure of their lobbying
campaign manif Orton Gates arranged for
the Center for a modern Ukraine to be
the nominal client of company a and B
even though in fact the center was under
ultimate direction of the government of
Ukraine
you knew kovitch in the Party of Regions
tied to Russia
it goes on at the direction of mana
foreign gates company a and Company B
engaged in extensive lobbying who are
they a company IND well we know that
five days ago NBC News reported that
Muller is investigating Democrat
lobbyist Tony Podesta the reason that
name rings a bell is he's the brother of
Hillary's campaign chairman John Podesta
many now this report went on and showed
that mana Ford had organized a PR
campaign
for this front group the European Center
for modern Ukraine Podesta's company was
one of the firms that worked on the
campaign the Podesta group also violated
the foreign agents Registration Act
because it only filed is a foreign agent
when it was exposed that they had so
they got caught and then retroactively
Lee they they registered his one just
this afternoon this broke about an hour
ago
Tony Podesta stepped down from the
Podesta group amid the investigation all
of the available evidence points to the
indictment in Ko painting not only a
major Democrat firm for undisclosed
lobbying on behalf of Russian interests
not only a major Clinton crony but
actually the brother of Hillary
Clinton's campaign chairman we're
talking about lobbying efforts that took
place between 2012 and 2014 that's at
least three years ago it's up to five
years ago what took so long
for the prosecution well I don't know
what do we know about Barack Obama's
executive agencies during that time we
know they were highly politicized we
know they selectively prosecuted
perceived enemies like Dinesh D'Souza
they targeted conservative Tea Party
groups through the IRS we know they
ignored major scandals like fast and
furious Hillary Clinton's email scandal
on and on and on is it possible that the
Obama administration didn't prosecute
this case for years because it would
have implicated top Hillary cronies in
the run-up to her presidential run the
timing sure does make you wonder